given an f of x and they say what is the
coefficient for the term containing x
plus 2 to the 4th power
in
the taylor polynomial centered at x
equals negative 2 of f
so like always take a see if you can
take a stab at this video on your own
before we work through it together
all right now let's let's do this so in
general our taylor polynomial p of x
it's going to have the form and remember
we're centering it x equals negative two
so this means we're going to evaluate
our function
at where we're centering it
we are going to divide it by zero
factorial which is just one i'm just
going to write it all out just so you
see the pattern and we could even say
that's going to be times x
minus where we're centering it but if
we're subtracting a negative 2 it's
going to be x plus 2 and i could write
to the 0th power but once again that's
just going to be 1. so a lot of times
you won't see someone write this and
this but i'm writing it just to show
that there's a consistent pattern so
then you're going to have plus
the first derivative evaluated at
negative 2
divided by 1 factorial which is still
just 1 times x plus 2 to the first power
plus
the second derivative evaluated at
negative 2
over 2 factorial
times x plus 2 squared i think you see
where this is going
and really all we care about is the one
that has a fourth degree term and well
actually let me just write the third
degree term too just to get fluent in
this so the third derivative evaluated
at negative two
over three factorial times x plus two to
the third power and now this is the part
that we really care about
plus
the fourth derivative
i could have just written a 4 there but
i think you get what i'm saying
and then evaluate at x equals negative 2
divided by 4 factorial times x plus two
to the fourth power so what's the
coefficient here well the coefficient is
this business
so we need to take the fourth derivative
of our original function
we need to take the fourth derivative of
that original function evaluated
negative two and divided by four
factorial so let's do that
so our function
so our first derivative f prime of x is
just going to be just gonna use the
power rule a lot 6 x to the fifth minus
three x squared
second derivative
is going to be equal to five times six
is thirty
x to the fourth two times three minus
six x to the first power
third derivative
third derivative of x is going to be
equal to 4 times 30
is 120 x to the third power
minus 6
and then the fourth derivative which is
what we really care about is going to be
3 times 120
is 360
x to the second power and the derivative
of constant's just 0.
so if we were to evaluate this at x
equals negative two
so
f the fourth derivative
evaluated when x equals negative two is
going to be 360 times negative two
squared is four i'm just going to keep
that as 360 times 4. we can obviously
evaluate that but we're going to divide
it by 4 factorial so the whole
coefficient is going to be 360 times 4
which is the numerator here divided by 4
factorial divided by 4 times 3 times 2
times 1.
well 4 divided by 4 those is going to be
1.
360 divided by
3. maybe i'll think of it this way 360
divided by 6 is going to be 60 and so
that's all we have we have 60 and then
the denominator denominators have a 1.
so this is going to simplify
to 60. that's the coefficient for this
term